how did you feel I got a family they
said how did you feel when how does it
feel to strike out Otani I mean it's
probably just a strikeout over soon but
you know expect let's go with this how
would it feel if otani's up it's second
and third two outs and you need this
it's uh I guess it would be the
bot or the top of the fifth bottom and
fifth whatever
with with two outs you need this out for
a
uh what's it when you go six six innings
in quality Star Quality star you need
this for a quality to start but you also
need it for a dub for the boys like and
you punched him out what would you do
yeah I mean I
probably it's not even just about him
this is just about more about the spot
but yeah I mean it's it's he's
unbelievable I mean it's uh there's not
there's not many holes in his in his
swing spots to go
um you gotta you know pick your spots
where you're gonna
you know challenge not challenge
whatever it is
um so yeah I mean it was it's crazy to
punch him out especially I mean you know
how it was Every Chain in his name like
or Chan coming to Seattle so yeah I was
like man it's so nice a chance for me to
come to Seattle that's that's awesome
um so yeah I was just like man if I if
he gets me right here I'm like this
place is going to go and it's going to
be everywhere
um so that's that's shout out to Sean
Murphy because I probably would have
threw him a 3-2 heater just because it's
All-Star game like whatever he called
the curveball if you threw a 3-2 heater
he would hit at 700 feet oh my gosh yeah
like that it would it would have one
thousand percent yeah unless I mean if I
miss if it was a ball I could have
walked yeah but if it was in a strike
zone he might have hit him yeah yeah to
the Pacific Ocean I don't know it was
like yeah do you um
I'm sure I'm sure you do but like how
much do you appreciate like kind of what
he is doing it's not I mean it's crazy
it's like
I mean I get like you know Babe Ruth did
what he did but like
this doesn't this is unbelievable
compared to babe and it's like it's
funny to hear people be like not that I
ever saw babe replay but like just from
the game of back then to now like to
people even put in the same conversation
it's like it's it's not even close
they're just he's one of those guys that
when you're done playing like I'll be
like I played against ohtani play
against the greatest player that we've
maybe I think we don't appreciate it
while we're playing you know I we do to
a certain degree but like we don't also
because we I think we get numb to it
yeah you're like okay like it's on MLB
Network you're like this guy's on there
again you're like but like he's throwing
100 and hitting balls 500. the thing
that I always get to like the picture
part of it because like I know how hard
hitting is but I don't at the same time
like you know how heart pitching is I
know how hard pitching is and that like
he just is gonna he's gonna SWAT 55 60
homers this year but then he's also
throws a hundred like that's the that's
the part that fires me up like this
guy's throwing a hundred like how many
guys are 100 in the big leagues yeah I
mean now a lot but not not they don't
hit 50 60 yeah they're like I mean
that's the thing it's like this guy is
gonna it's it's fascinating really